from screen jumping studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
moving fight now your host Andy signor
hello screen junkies welcome to a
championship battle here the winner of
today's fight will finally go into a
belt battle against our champion mr.
dead serious
that was a very Oprah oh yeah I can't
wait this is epic you got three
challenges cash to earn their right here
through three different three different
methods man got here because Manson roca
wanted to fight the mayor Soroka they
deserved it they've earned it over the
times but you beat gonna get here Scott
Maxwell Camus VIII man thank you so much
screen don't you face let's do this
you very nervous here now if one of you
guys win you will go on a one-on-one
fight the gotham anime are different but
I'm not nervous from frightening all
right well that's going to get exciting
next up you won the fan choice round
hashtag platonic oh my hi hello everyone
I've got my costume of man and a little
tiny green hat today I'm excited to be
back and I'm ready to go how are you
feeling nerves no come on a little bit
you're sure I mean no this look this
shows a nightmare - do you have like no
time to prepare you have to run
frantically right into movies I haven't
seen Rob Reider before to start yeah I
go on a Wikipedia anyway so it's fine
I'm fine
everything's good all right yeah can I
point out for posterity by the way that
Mike Carlson also beer okay to get here
yeah no cheats' Roca is a friend in my
book well Mike you had a shot at the
belt way long ago one of our first line
here's ago when I usually I think has
had a shine against Dan again you took
him down you've had the belt the whole
line this is getting exciting I who
knows but I liked the battle you had
against max where you chose for the Bell
Dada is really one fight but one-on-one
fight
to be worthy and then we'll see what
happens after that but some exact last
up he won the what was yours called it
wasn't Android I just kept winning
you're damn straight
de welcome the chance right Dan got to
pick three people he wanted them to
fight you got that list and you that was
a really tough battle yeah I'm Dan's
brain if you put a lot of tough fighters
on I understand where he's come from you
want to fight the best and that's why
I'm excited to fight my characters I
don't watch him like I'm not doing here
but I played you before I played you
before I just want to play new pony to
see how I play against them I did beat
you once before I'm looking forward to
trying to beat like today I have to be
those were either a tough match I'm just
saying I was there you fighting kind of
you fought might perform not never
fought wow what a Comic Con I think
right yeah it was a prayer for anything
so here today this is going to be
exciting and wow you got to see today
mr. Andrew bluesy Oh welcome on the fan
cam man you pick a good one to be here
today
thanks I usually watch the show work out
so psyched to be able to get up and come
nice what do you do I'm security guard
oh good that's not important yeah no
pretty quick hair and put someone in
your place but no I'm glad you could be
here watching in real life I'm gonna
come to you for help so pay attention
it's about the arguments you know how
this goes yeah I watch every week all
right what do you want to show up do you
have a favorite are you going to show
your car Jan you give me your vest
I keep it under that hello chairman I
haven't fired let's get my card once you
write your favorite in them yeah old
again that's a great I'll get you a card
and we can reveal at the end who you
think is going to win okay max and make
sure we get them a card before it's over
very good all right guys get semantic
are you notice how this all we know all
the Steamworks we're gonna do it so I'll
passion fashion creativity yes said Wow
look he's got the shirt he's ready to go
ready to go first level and mention is
there if you're playing at home and want
a drink it's probably a shot every time
man springs up a lot of land or anybody
from all away
all right it's just like this
what a lovely night by a 90/10 fight all
right here we go round one
this key this is one based off the money
which opened open opening Thursday and
Friday well look the reviews have not
been kind as Dan said my favorite pun
ever you will not want to spend your
socotra crop of us man so yes it might
be a rat for the dark the universe has
started but we want to give it an
injection we want to do something good
here so we want you guys to pitch the
actor and universal monster that should
join and could save this dark universe
what do we want to see next what's a
movie and what's a monster and a
celebrity that can save this franchise
and turn it into the right direction who
do we want to see who's playing the
monster Jason you can pick for many of
the universal monster movies yeah go
ahead they got a save it already huh
that's not good news I haven't seen the
movie yet I'm going to go with one of
the best actors working saying the
reason why I did that is because you
look at that picture of all those actors
they're not going just for action you're
talking to Cathy walk in the catheter
here is Johnny Depp Javier Bardem
Russell Crowe Tom Cruise sofia boutella
like there's great actors there yes they
have a long history of being Award
winners winning Oscars so I want
something I could walk into that room
with that cast and hold his own and that
for that one with Dracula I'm going
Michael Fassbender the reason why don't
go Michael Fassbender is because this
guy is probably one of the best actors
working today by far and I think he's
even better when he's going evil I mean
12 years of slave he reached another
level evil which I think disturbed him I
love magneto because Magneto's character
you kinda understand where he's coming
from you look at Bram Stoker's Dracula
one reason I love that movies you kind
of get where blacks coming from Vlad the
Impaler I took a picture there from
Macbeth because you can play the
old-school
Vlad with the flashbacks depending on
however the director wants to do it
but I feel like he could also just come
in and with those group of actors demand
a scene in dracula by far the ones that
were left in that list that's who you
need a cast next after your big one I
mean Frankenstein Wolfman Dracula
Dracula at the top he is the Iron Man of
that franchise really Drago is more
popular than the mummy I think you the
money is like the side character you
also know how is it I think you all
picked one is probably harder than money
here we go microwave at me definitely
know a lady gentlemen I have chosen the
character of the Phantom of the Opera
which they just announced a no need to
chuckle the fan of the Opera will be in
the dark universe and I think let's
think about the Phantom of the Opera of
course my favorite version of him is the
Andrew Lloyd Webber version from the
musical now Phantom of the Opera is a a
tortured man he's disfigured but he is
oddly alluring and you know strangely
sexual and he is a very unusual unique
magnetic charisma so what actor fits all
these things you know what actors
alluring what actor is oddly sexual and
has a magnetic charisma Jeff Goldblum
there he is
now imagine he has I'm in my version of
the Phantom of the Opera he has that
half mask like in the Andrew Lloyd
Webber version let's check some boxes ok
phantom the opera is a musician he plays
a piano he composes music Jeff Goldblum
knows how to play the piano I've seen
him play at the Rockwell on Vermont in
Los Angeles very good it's a very good
show because he owned the club no
because he just came is there a lot
III don't like what I'm watching a movie
and I see they cut away to some other
man's hands playing that's going to be
important I want this guy to actually be
able to play you know the organ or the
piano get Ryan Gosling ok take a choice
- everybody shut up so I'm gonna ignore
that look so uh in the fly we've seen
the Goldblum can play a guy who's
already like who's you know
transforming into a monster or is
already sort of this figure so we know
he can do that turmoil but on top of
that this is Jeff Goldblum this is one
of the weirdest most fun unique actors
around and he has not been
a big movie that people liked in a long
time I think this is somebody who when
paired with the right character and the
right franchise is going to be your Tony
Stark your Iron Man somebody that can
lead a franchise through multiple movies
alright Jeff man all right listen you
want you want someone you want an actor
who is going to to be fresh someone's
going to really inject something fresh
and fun and different into the dark
universe clearly that is what this
series has got a need because the money
looks too much like the other mummy it
felt to conventional formulaic it felt
like something we've seen before so
let's make this dark universe character
something different something we haven't
seen that is why I see Margot Robbie is
the wolf not the wolf man Margot Robbie
is the was a Jack Nicholson Michelle
Pfeiffer what like like a here's okay
here's the pitch okay so Margot Robbie
plays Lizzie Talbot
she is a sexy successful ambitious
wardrobe designer living in LA she's
really mean she's really mean to the
people that she works with and works for
she's kind of like Meryl Streep in The
Devil Wears Prada so she's all filming
the film in the English countryside she
goes into the woods looking for
something for one of the costumes she
gets bit by a werewolf now she has the
curse she goes back to LA and there it
is
she is she's nominated for an Academy
Award for her previous film she wins the
award and when she goes up to collect it
it is a full moon in Hollywood and happy
about any awards in front of millions of
people around the world she turns into a
werewolf and everybody thinks it is a
special effect and it's a gag but it's
real and so out the course of the film
she learns to be a better person she
wants to open her heart so she becomes
she becomes a better person because of
the werewolf curse this is something
that is going to be different it is a
mix it's a mixture of action comedy and
thrilling suspense and a love story
a throwback to an American world in
London but set in LA it's an America
where often london Meets The Devil Wears
Prada meets lala land
Jesus so okay I got ya guys you have to
write it down so she's going to become a
better person to murdering a bunch of
people I mean I'm a better person
because she's got this curse and she
doesn't know what to do with it and it
just shakes up her whole life how's this
tie into the leg all these great actors
in the universe like okay how is she she
turned to where Oscars that sounds like
a comedy essentially epic movie it is a
comedy it's a hard common engine to come
that's an American an American war often
London's was great because it was a
comedy and it was great at being a
horrible year that's what this ear
pinching a bottle the Wolfman movie that
has nothing to do with this dark
universe I put dark universe I can
remove a sounds very fun and light to me
not dark and different and something
that this franchise will need in order
to end yeah but it needs to fit
franchise and I don't think Margot
Robbie has really had that grave a track
record she was not very good at alleged
Tarzan she wasn't very good at focus I
mean both of Wall Street's the only
thing I can really say okay that was a
good performance but I haven't seen the
kind of range I would put her in this
kind of movie oh my God look at the wolf
of Wall Street she stole that night a
million are DiCaprio were you having you
stole Mary Lee billion there was not a
literal wolf and Wolf of Wall Street
girl thank you she was awaiting money
coming yeah Mike I need you to teach me
how the Phantom is gonna work in this
movie before you even give me or even
get to Jeff go away it's a movie about
the Phantom of the Opera it's a movie
about the family opera healthy I can
tell you the plot of Phantom of the
Opera how does he work with these clue
the wolf man Dracula like what's he
doing what is he like just singing there
damn you connected why I don't want to
connect a venture saying when they team
up ya know in our universe it's a dark
years how what's he doing he's playing
dirty music so actually doing like don't
don't you certainly does play the theme
okay that is you have heart of it but he
wanted to you he has looked he's a
mustiness sneak he sneaks around sneaks
around okay he's a guy that can get into
places he's a guy that vanishes
mysteriously he is sort of a leader he's
an overseer he's a sort on type in this
universe he's not a guy maybe on the
ground Frankenstein is your brute force
you know Dracula is you know fighting
he'd have like he's wearing a cape he
has a mask on a list there like there's
an action scene at like a play or a
stage somewhere I
don't know how he's going to come into
this animator is the home here is the
home base okay that's ridiculous I mean
I don't want it really Milky Way the
home base with the other monsters to
come and like smack out yeah like
there's multiple home bases because
they're obviously going to have
adventures all over the globe so there's
caves there's different places and yes
his theater also when the bowels of the
theater yeah where he's sort of watching
over all right well I want all of you to
connect because I all right interesting
solo films but again the question who do
you want to join the unit the dark
universe tell me how they're going to
then eventually carry in I get it strong
soul over the now are they going to save
this this franchise that tell me how to
interact or without a monster what else
happens good well I see Fassbender is
first of all he is kind of like the
connective tissue between all these
people this he dates back before maybe
not before the mummy but all the way
back before everybody else and I think
Russell Crowe scary now I haven't seen
the movie so we're just going on the
actor well how we think they actually
senses universe I just think what those
actors and what vast bender could bring
to that role I need somebody I know
could go in there and absolutely
dominate the screen with some of the
best working actors in Hollywood Interac
EULA I could see him starting off as
maybe the bad guy because I think these
guys don't have a big bad again I
haven't seen mommy bow know who's big
bad is alright this guy could literally
be the one he could be their Thanos okay
here's the thing first of all both even
guys alright your pics are good but they
are too conventional Michael Fassbender
is a great actor like Fassbender as
Dracula it's not different enough it
doesn't shake up the Cinematic Universe
formula enough neither does Jeff
Goldblum is not a conventional choice
anyway so it's not really a good choice
either you have to make a good movie in
a while and when he try graduate on the
golden but on Independence Day
resurgence that movie was awful people
didn't really go see the movie and he's
certainly not a box-office draw where
Margot Robbie comes in as the wolf is
that that if you have her part of this
dark universe you have the other members
Tom Cruise of The Mummy you have Russell
Crowe you know dr. Jekyll vying for her
affection so because you have a woman in
the mix it shakes up the gender dynamic
it throws some dramatic tension it first
some love tension into the next that you
would not have with a male actor and I
Got News for you in the wolf of Wall
Street okay
Margot Robbie shouldn't steal the movie
but she definitely held her
own wit Leonardo DiCaprio and she can
hold her own with Tom Cruise and she can
hold her own with Russell Crowe and by
the way guys this will be the perfect
follow-up for Margot Robbie after her
smash box office hit miss pac-man okay
Sarah this is my caricature well the the
feelin the Phantom of the Opera is the
person that brings them all together he
is the one what do you mean what if
anything you should be like Hawkeye he
should show up halfway through the movie
and go away by the end of it he can't
lead his own you know like the Nick Fury
oh god that's wrote the problem never
never came I didn't roll off his
ventures and the beyond me
obviously like he does not deserve his
own film he does not dare makin any
films of The Phantom of the Opera yes he
does deserve his own film I'm just
saying that he has the he's not going to
take like up for front-of-the-line role
in this he is a backseat player but he
pops up and when you see him he's
delightful vesical does of course he
came he's the Phantom of the Opera he's
a brilliant musician what Goldblum is
going to be peppered throughout a big
heavy action movie and you're going to
be delighted by his scenes he's going to
break up things with some humor with
with relieving tension like best
Goldblum that's what you want from him
he's a fun side character lands like
he's in my movies okay I get that yeah
as an ensemble he does add that to the
mix but we have look margot robbie i
mean again it's an unconventional pick
but it's all about the argument it's not
it's not always about the choice it's
about the argument and what's going to
happen with Margot Robbie it's like I
said she's going to shake up the dynamic
and as we saw last weekend with Wonder
Woman that shook up the dynamic people
are ready to see a strong female hero
like Wonder Woman like Margot Robbie as
the wolf you're going to bring out a
strong female contingent of movie goers
that might not normally see a movie
about archiving right I'm in the
hundred-mile cause behind fountain I'm
not against the fact that you want women
to play The Wolfman I'm against the
actress he picked I don't think she's
right for the role I don't think she's
proven enough that she can hold her own
against those actors that they have cast
so far I feel like Michael Fassbender
walks in that room I don't care what
movie it is he stole the scene
inglorious basterds he literally just
will go to the forefront and he'll make
me
I can just see giant death and all his
own actions like cower in a scene with
him and feel like that's Dracula he's
the one guy that walks in the room
everyone shuts up
I think fast but is when the only actor
is working today with that crew that
could actually deliver that kind of
performance Mike okay look Margot
Robbie's great she could certainly hold
their own as an actress but I think the
wolf I don't know that that's exactly
the right role for I think there's
probably something else that you could
do that could be a little bit better and
as far as fast better I mean yeah he's a
powerhouse he's great but it's a very
dry casting of Dracula my Dracul I like
Klaus Kinski I like Bella look I'll Ike
Gary Oldman these are Mike Dracula he's
a weird guy these are guys that are
going to bring this like really specific
uniqueness to it and that's what
Goldblum will do with the Phantom I was
seeing the old bloom at while he pledged
as we were waiting in line for it okay
and Goldblum showed up and this is true
story Goldblum what there was a line of
people there to get in heat for no
reason went up and down the line talking
to everybody and like seducing them like
not literally but like hello hello how
are you so good to see you I'm like no
one knows them and I'm like this the
most seductive man I've ever seen this
guy's incredible he's going to bring
that to this role he's going to bring
incredibly unique spirit that Goldblum
has and it's going to give him a big hit
that he deserves to have because he's
amazing he's a national treasure for
God's sake you magnify God and Amaral
yes when the fed of the Opera before
being a musical was one of universals
first monster movies back in the early
20s with lon chaney not launching junior
at lon Cheney playing the phantom a lot
of people are kind of a chiming in
online Antony Harrington says Wesley
Snipes as blade as Dracula David Bowman
says Mads Mikkelsen would be an
excellent Dracula Anthony Hernandez
those Creature from the Black Lagoon
played by Andy Serkis and tricycle
effects created by guillermo del toro
idea die agra tom sambito says a Kevin
Spacey's voice and presence would be
great even if you don't see his face as
the Invisible Man so a lot of a letter
has a constriction a lot of a lot of
good good tunes coming
Twitter of course we have the Twitter
poll which is out there I'm looking at
the results now it say that there is a
leader but we'll see what Andy rules
Andrew what do you stream what would you
want to say I'd want to see Fassbender
it's Dracula I feel like it could take
it to some pretty dark places and that
spectacular should be alright I mean
that's right buddy that's where my head
was going to sort of a great
conventional safe I mean look based on
arguments I think JT wins Fassbender
makes the most sense but my heart man my
heart really wants to see Goldblum of
course it's the best I mean I updated
the clothes in the film I can't ask the
answer to survive an argument because
it's what you haven't seen the film I
had it I brought things get going crazy
cuz your judgement of these are actors
in the film they're not really actors in
this totally I can't get about deaf I'm
here by Jen or sure I'm moving forward
with their and they're all they're sort
of chewing the scenery up a little bit
yeah I can't go with my heart I got to
go with argument gypsy at the point big
gal your closest trip setting there
wasn't Margo votes I'm sorry that she
she gets she turns to the Academy Award
how much fun out of me I mean she turns
any category everybody everybody thinks
it's like oh wow what a great special
what a great stunt okay I no one knows
except her
wait but is she playing herself yeah
that's right now to my side are she
playing what I'm a fashion designer who
wears an Academy Award but to promote
look whatever I receive all right round
two right hand Margot Robbie in this
pack I'm sorry what were the fan polls
there Dan bands agree with you 47
percent voted for Dracula Fassbender 29
percent phantom of the Goldblum 24
percent Margot Robbie wolf Thank You 24
percent you guys Rock
let's go to one that we haven't had a
chance to talk about this is old news
but it's only that's been asked a ton um
top gun to announce we
I wear to tighten to receive um so we
want to know who should direct us movie
so here we go round two who should
direct Top Gun to Tony Scott we lost
them that was sad he's a wonderful
director he can't come back to do this
so who takes the mantle to try and make
us film because there was this is a the
most Tony Scott movie you could make
definitely um so I want to know your
choices are you're welcome to pitch some
of what your movie would be but tell us
Mike you're up first
okay Top Gun is like a brownie
masterpiece okay we need somebody who is
in that mindset somebody who understands
that already and somebody who's going to
deliver what we want from a Top Gun
sequel I'm talking Michael Bay alright
if you want the intense action if you
want great shot of dudes abs this is the
guy you want you want a guy who
understands the bro movie okay we're
talking pain in game we're talking bad
boys these are movie not just a robot
man he's a guy who can do other things
and he had we seen it and those movies
are good people like those movies that
look we can't get it exactly right we
can't give the same filmmakers so we're
going to get the next best thing it's a
guy who who understands the mentality of
these very aggressive dudes all right
Matt's okay my pick for Top Gun maverick
the director is Justin Lin because what
you're going to want it's fast and
furious in the air and who better to do
fast and furious in the air than the
director of Cal for Fast and Furious
movies but what he did with Fast Five
was not just direct another Fast and
Furious movie that movie changed it
changed the whole series it changed the
direction of the whole series it infused
a new life into it if Reta heard it by
making it fit a Fast and Furious meets
Ocean's eleven so if there's anybody
who's going to take an old film and do a
sort of sequel slash reboot make it
fresh and different it's going to be
just a Lin he's great with action and
he's also great with strong character
development the way he establish
the characters in The Fast and Furious
films that he did especially Fast Five
and fast six it was all about family and
then look what he did with Star Trek
beyond he put the series back on track
quality wise would Star Trek beyond it
was a great action film and the
characters were fully realized and
dynamic you need fully realized and
dynamic characters in an action film
otherwise who cares this time is going
to be since it's thirty years later and
maverick is thirty years old or he's
past his prime he's going to take it
upon himself to train his young hotshot
sexy confident irresistible Protege
played by Emma Stone
Emma Stone has her incredible range she
has a toughness about her she can hold
her own with Tom Cruise
I think if there's anybody who's going
to play a young maverick style hotshot
pilots it's got to be an association in
this one she's not even in him oh my god
she's a same age that Tom Cruise was in
the Eroica got it all right Katie
alright this was a hard question and I
went through a lot of choices as if I
ultimately ended up with Shane black and
here's the reason why first of all this
guy came from the 80s this guy wrote
predator lethal weapon he was around
with Top Gun was in its prime when a
movie came out he was already working in
the industry and this guy has proven
that he knows how to action with Iron
Man 3 now I don't think it's a great MCU
so my think it's a great shame black
film I think it was the wrong material
for him I think for him it's all about
dialogue the characters and adding a
little bit of humor and when I think Top
Gun yeah the five scenes are great but
some of my favorite scenes from talkin
are the stuff like in the locker room
just the guys interact with each other
the competition Kilmer improves just
going after each other and he knows how
to write dialogue he knows how to have
that fun vibe and I think he'll bill to
make it more modern without losing all
that 80's cheese he'll touch on it he'll
even probably poke fun at it a little
bit and I think he would be a perfect
choice because he's a director who's
working both decades and I think he's
made that transition from a writer to a
director and he really knows how to do
cool action scenes that kind of play
against type my thing is with Top Gun I
don't want to feel like an eighty to top
the movie I want to feel like a Top Gun
we for today
feel like he would actually destroy it
I'll get more into the plot as we
continue alright find it out guys okay
Mike away from Mike Gesell informants
gthe lies a two-way flight Bay get outta
here yeah no way there is a visible
makeup I don't really take me because
you don't want to make a cop gun movie
that's going to feel too much like the
80s tank gun well I feel like Michael
Bay is going to do that because like you
said he's going to make the dues but the
ads that's been done you got to shake
that up and you got to make currents and
I don't think that he would he's too far
so I think he's too sexist I think he
makes generally everybody
no no I want Top Gun maverick to be a
great film and Tom Cruise is going to
need it after the moment Richard Hopkins
were talking about so maybe you know
what are the best abilities of the age
don't underplay nerd what Top Gun
actually has some sincere mounatin mood
when goose dies I shall hardly imagine
of Michael Bay directed Top Gun 1 and
did that scene it mean Pearl Harbor all
that it would just be flags waving
slow-motion come out of the water I'm
like what am i watching right now I'm
not feeling anything
and the smaller moments in the movie Top
Gun is when the characters are
interacting just seeing that the bar
were there singing there's actual charm
Michael Bay has the worst sense of humor
of any action director I've ever seen no
here's your mom is horrible I can't see
him playing those small fun moments at
all cuz they won't be small fun moments
they'll be huge dumb moments that are
punching you in the face
Michael Bay would be horrible the
directives movie people going to Top Gun
do wanna see an 80s to something to the
80s new 2017 version Top Gun there's
already be Gators been watching they
were say a touch of the ativ they want
to see volleyball they want an uncommon
all in a handsome man might even wanna
you do that in a smart way
a lot of people got news for you they
have not seen Top Gun so they're going
to need to go in to see Top Gun a brain
and it's got I feel like a lot of
appeal to people as a stand-alone film
the only way you're going to do that is
to sort of make it like a mentor-protege
type of film kind of like Tom Cruise and
Paul Newman and the color of money but
again I'm just using a very broad
outline for that this is about a you
know this is about a man finding purpose
and a woman finding her identity and and
you know why I agree with you Shane
black it's great with dialogue but you
know what it's Top Gun I'm not it's not
inception it's not it's not even a Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang I want good action and I
want good characters and I feel like
Justin Lin has the perfect balance to
bring it all to the table all right guys
good opening argument there I want to
hear why yours though is the best for
Top Gun specifically here I go goes
right back to Justin win because you
want the perfect blend up action and you
want the perfect blend of heart and good
character and I feel like Justin Lin
really does have that Michael Bay
doesn't I mean well everything of your
argument is going back to the 80s you
want it to be for 2018 or 2019 when the
movie comes out so you're going to want
something that feels current and fresh
and stands on its own does not provide
too much on 80s nostalgia and Justin Lin
what he did again with fancified and
with Star Trek beyond putting both of
those franchises back on track making
them fresh and vibrant and different is
what Top Gun maverick needs and that's
what it will get with him as a director
you look at peer you look at you look at
paying a game which is like a period
piece it is a movie that is modern well
it is I mean it's not in modern day but
you take the characters out from that
and put in topic on what movie feels
like how come that movie feels like it
the Sun sets the way he shoots things
that movie visually is going to remind
you the most of South gone there's no
way that we want to see a top gun that
strips itself of the fun cheesiness of
the 80s that is so much of a big part of
it we need to preserve that my Justin
Lin honestly too much nuance we don't
want that much new ones Shane black too
much humor we don't want this thing to
be like Winky Winky isn't it's a goofy
movie that's not going to work for this
we need a guy who
like sincerely loves America a guy who
sincerely like understands what guys are
like in the locker room like whether you
agree maybe you wouldn't be my best
friend but he think I know and
understand that my head would be in the
locker room with these guys you can see
Michael Bay like mad-dogging other guys
while they're shirtless in a locker room
he is these guys I am like that's why
you want to put Emma Stone in the locker
room to like one day is not the one guy
want to be friends with in the locker
room like I wanted to be a misogynist
Pig and they're probably take the deal
and let me talk a little Justin when the
guy when it comes to flying jets is all
about speed air you know physics yeah he
doesn't care about that
you see those there's a runway for about
18 miles cars are doing 16 flips like
there's no gravity also it took them to
fast affairs moves before he finally
made a good one with five
Tokyo Drift and for our pretty and to
back your practice underrated its
underrated completing recitation other
properties also Star Trek beyond was not
great yes applause sorry I know your
Star Trek famous doctor I do a lot of
people who left that movie kind of
underwhelmed like I just did equate it
it felt like an episodic thing which I'm
integrating what team went for but I
don't think it works for that big movie
franchise that they were going I thought
it did just a difference of opinion I
thought it did but I hope she ain't
black by the way one of the best
performers Val Kilmer has ever given was
in Kiss Kiss Bang Bang let's bring him
back as Iceman when a guy who knows how
to write for him it can make him just as
crazy and nuts as he was in the first
movie there's already a working
relationship there and Tom Cruise doing
shame back dialogue
Tom Cruise needs after movies like Jack
Reacher and The Mummy he needs someone
that knows how to write for him and can
make him back to like a character that
we actually care about like you're Jerry
Maguire he needs a good script I think
Shane black and bring that to him in
action he knows how to shoot act him so
well now okay if you want Tom Cruise to
have a writer director who writes for
him well bringing Christopher McQuarrie
he did a great job with him for Mission
Impossible rogue nation and he also did
touch-ups on on detective oh yeah why
are you talking McCoy
looking for a lighter if you're looking
for a writer before enjoying our wine a
director in one but that's what listen
first of all in defense of Star Trek
beyond you know that's known as I can
hardly these both these directors are
good but Michael Bay is the one who's
going to understand Top Gun the most I
mean don't want like this Winky
self-referential Top Gun like that's not
we don't want like a Baywatch style
thing and Justin Lin honestly Justin Lin
is probably more of a guy I would hang
out with it doesn't make sense for him
to to direct [ __ ] will have to do
with anything I'm not like the guys job
going I'm the opposite of the guys in
cop so we decided lightweight guys in
Top Gun that's a guy who won cause if
you take if you put fast five on in the
air
you've got Top Gun maverick it's going
down the speed it's about you want you
want a Top Gun movie that's going to
feel even more visceral and more fun and
more and more fast and talk about the
need for speed Justin Lin will do that
and get fast eight was ridiculous but he
did direct that he'd been person like
five and six for the best one but or
Diggins it doesn't fit Freight Hopkins
Hopkins ridiculous because video it's
because of certain situations not
because of the planes are doing 360s hop
girls running let's be clear Top Gun is
ridiculous thank you thank you
ridiculous
that is the point I'm trying to make no
you know Brandi AEDs differ here oh and
now we're going to strip it away we're
not really done we're going to ground it
in reality and I know they move along
that's why she block is actually not a
good director he's too sophisticated for
tying on to me okay limb is also did you
pain indicated when it's not
sophisticated a key then a perfect the
rail community he is no nominee
background he's very good able to action
you went hard you want humor
Justin Lana it's the real shame black
next film is predator he's not too
classy to make Top Gun this guy is
perfect for making 80s movies for today
you haven't seen predator oh it's a
great like the newest red camera is
going to look great it's going to sexy
but it's going to have maybe a color
palette that reminds you
he's no way his movies gonna look any
crappy in twenty-seventh any director
can shoot a golden hour that's the only
reason why I think you want BAE's
because you want those golden hour
showers I wasn't don't worry you I hold
an hour like Micheal Mahoney's captain
is report of an hour they don't call
them now Tony Scott did it before him in
days of tundra and token before bay was
even doing it bristle he used to be mr.
golden hour and now Michael Bay's
alright golden hour final thoughts here
okay final Tanja okay here you go I'm
just motivating along sector but who
remakes that oh this is what we want
this is it you never one knows this
track from who tell me I'm going to
Kenny Loggins danger zone how was your
director taking some dangers I want the
need for speed who does speed better
than Justin Lin look he did four frickin
car movies he could do a fighter jet
movie it'll be like a breath of fresh
air for him to put cars in the air and
go even faster do you want the need for
speed he's your guy okay you want you
want you don't want a Winky you want a
guy who's going to take it as seriously
as the first movie does you want look if
Justin won and Shane black they walk
into a room and Top Gun is on and it's
the volleyball scene I bet both of them
would like Chuck a little but all that's
kind of cheesy Michael Bay walks in the
room goes hell yeah great scene that's a
great scene in a great movie that's the
guy one directing it I'm not / this
isn't the most right I've ever been
Savini
you want Michael Bay to remake Top Gun I
want Shane black to do a ride to look
good with Creed I wanted to make it for
modern times but still make it cool and
still give you remind you of the
original films that made it you love it
in the first place I feel like Shane
black could do the same thing where I
include leaden Creed I think he can
update it but he was around in idiots as
a rotten idea no I think last better
he's worked with Kilmer Jesus to see the
screen great screenwriter not thinking
against a smaller moments often out of
this guy that are more part to me than
in sense
all right Dan anything to clean up there
whoo Wow
so where did it even start I know and I
was actually just kind of sucked into
the conversation right now for the rent
of Tron Legacy and oblivion director
Julia Basinski is rumored to be
considering the movie not between the
Tom Cruise connection with oblivion
there Scott you mentioned that Tom
Cruise and Emma Stone about the same age
when both top guns four years apart
about four years apart yeah Tom Cruise
is about 34 top that came out in a
stomer probably about 30 so you know
roughly the same age and we have our
Twitter poll which Andy once you make
your ruling I will share with you the
results of that one of you really
connected with him here I gotta be
honest one of you really showed me the
passion one of you truly took my breath
away I think is me it wasn't you Jamie
you even got distracted saying Ryan
Coogler I got distracted saying Larry
there is one man who knows how to do
this and I saw the passion the
creativity Mike Carlson for the win
thank you that was some brilliant
fighting I didn't know I cared about
that until just now I didn't know but
now I care like the man that seems in
yeah yes 100% true all right there on
the board strangely a Shane black took
the audience's breath away 44% Booker's
new blog is a fan poll 31% jessalyn only
25% Michael Bay although I would agree
with you Andy based on the arguments
Mike's passion and the fact that I
literally believe that you thought that
you had never been more right that you
were about this yes passion why in
defense of Star Trek beyond I um shut up
with love round three all right well
this is what things are going to take a
bit of a turn another question about
you're trying something new that's right
this is a championship fight we wanted
to try something here and try it out
this will be called an advantage round
that's right for the next three rounds
we have tailor-fit a question to your
strength you got to choose the question
you got to have first choice so Mike
Carlson you have the first advantage
round now let me be clear because what
you don't know is if you win your
advantage round Mike you will learn a
regular point however if Scott or jte
win this round they will win double
points I guess you mean it goes against
imagine and takes down their opponent
who had the advantage again okay you
will earn double points for Lou you guys
understand yeah all right why do you
each have the advantage shake it up
shake it up everyone do it alright so
Mike you have the advantages as yours to
lose tell us why don't you tell us what
your question is what's the phrasing can
I see it
[Laughter]
Mike Carlton advantage round the
question is what movie character would
open the best chain restaurant all right
Mike you get to go nightmare to go first
all right to start a success big success
huh to start a successful business you
need a lot of capital okay that's number
one I'm I've chosen one of the richest
boys in the entire world if not the
richest boy I'm talking about Richie
Rich okay this is a guy Larry is we all
remember the iconic cult movie oh yeah
all right look here's the thing with a
chain restaurant you need a simple menu
people don't want some fancy you know
like a Coast West Coast sort of
liberally food they want cheeseburgers
they want grilled cheese they want stuff
that everyone eats a kid has the perfect
palate for that a kid loves food like
that so Ritchie's going to be perfect at
tasting and figuring out a menu now the
rich family also employs some of the
best chefs in the world because they're
very rich and that's what rich people do
so they're going to curate an incredible
menu all right now chain restaurants
need a system of shipping and freezing
meat and different things that rolls
bread to get to the to get to the extra
restaurant Richie Richie root Richie
Rich
has a friend named professor keenbean my
professor keenbean is a world's greatest
scientists he has developed a system for
freezing and storing and transporting
meat that is going to save everyone a
ton of money when it comes to this so
this restaurant is gonna be so
successful
of course Brown okay I'm just curious
professor keenbean was a guy who blew
the whole scandal wide open John
Larroquette character was trying to kill
his parents and take over now I don't
remember this is a movie that we all
remember come on I found it all right
I'm only about 10% after my pizza all
right
so professor keenbean has come up with
these systems of cooking and
transporting and it's going to be
amazing because it's going to save so
much money now you're thinking okay what
is the seeming look like because the
chain restaurant needs to have a theme
for sure here's the thing it looks just
like a TGI Fridays because that's what
people like so it's TGI Fridays no no
it's not it looks similar to its nicer
it's a TGI Fridays but it looks nicer
it's not the same thing but that's what
people like people like a bunch of crap
on the walls but the crest kind of crap
lately
Oh suitcases alligators like stuffed
alligator sounds like writing yeah but
it's better they're better like a
quality toy better quality to Kane right
now here's the kicker here's the thing
that is really going to separate this
from a normal Fridays or a Chili's or
something because you're a little kid
there's going to be a play area there's
going to be a MacDonald land play place
type of a thing and Richie has some
pretty great friends from the Harvey
comics universe so we're going to have
different rides and stuff that are
themed to his friends you know so
they'll be like you know Hot Stuff the
little devil ball pit there's going to
be you know a little dot slide there's
going to be a Casper slide which is also
a pun which is very fun because that's a
song that people like there are going to
be you know statues and fun ideas and
all like we're going to talk we're going
to talk about Ritchie's other friends
like little Lada and spooky the tuff
enuf little ghost he's going to have a
drawing easel where kids are going to
have fun this is going to be the
ultimate chain restaurant it's got
something for kids got something for
adults and you're going to get meals
that are dependable and delicious and
they're going to save so much money
because of professor keenbean
innovations as first genius for money
the consumer or the
on to the restaurant or okay so he's not
passing the city Atlanta that you know
he's the same it cost the same no more
right about the name better plan [ __ ]
he riches family restaurant okay okay
great
good start and good good use of your
advantage there Mike thank you master
cup neck okay you want a a character
from a film that's known for a film to
open up a chain one of the greatest film
characters even though he started off in
a book he's better known for the film
one of the greatest movies of all time
is the Godfather The Godfather about an
Italian families rise to power Vito
Corleone's Italian restaurant Vito's
Italian restaurant talk about an offer
you can't refuse
he already has the olive oil business
down he's got capital he's very rich but
this is a place you go to where you were
treated with respect you are treated
like a real Godfather
they'll kill you'll want the meal so
much that you'll try to get out and
they'll keep pulling it back in the food
exactly well canary listen and you know
you'll lead the guns you'll take the
cannoli and I guess what
try the veal it's the best in town
Vito's Italian restaurant you think of
time you think pasta you think lasagna a
pizza this is a classy restaurant it is
a chain it is above the other chains
like Burger King and Roy Rogers and
McDonald's it is class and it is Italian
and it's the gun it's a tall where'd you
put it on the chain next to like buco to
Peppa yeah Bob poopy the target is more
affordable the book at the Palais
Maggiano's level it's even greater it's
it's it's the Godfather okay so it is
the top pricing menu very affordable
similar to Maggiano's chilean what to
like Olive Garden Wow okay okay no it's
affordable I mean you want if it's going
to be a change it has to be affordable
right so we're
[ __ ] Italian level two real and I'll
regard equality with always pricing that
there's much better quality nobody is
more qualified to make quality are
passing on the savings may be to the
detriment of the biscuits got it yes JC
a good I'm going with a character that
actually is popular and I think
everybody knows others a problem oh yeah
like I'm sure like 50 year olds electing
me the Corleone's no they're not they're
gonna want to go to dead pulls Jimmy
effin changose okay this guy is already
he's all look at this picture he's
already endorsing it and his movie
trailers all the time you look at the
Photoshop that is not Photoshop I took
that photo myself okay right here I took
it myself I don't believe there's
several photos of hitman chimichangas I
feel like if you're going to have a
franchise be special today I can't just
look like TGIF it can't just go off one
little property it has to go off
something that is universally big right
now and Deadpool is by far with most
five point combo characters hands-down
right it made more money than every
x-men movie in almost every MCU film
outside the Avengers it is just so
ingrained in the pop culture that this
restaurant student accepted you feel
like you're in Deadpool just colossus
the classic shakes Columbus shakes
that's all right
classic Colossus really there's a hot
sauce called a teenage warhead hot sauce
like everything is themed to the movie
you go in there and I remember that
restaurant dicks or anyone treats you
come again after close resort every
single waiter is dressed like Deadpool
and he's giving you a hard time
oh Jesus yeah listen you're signing up
for that when you go in now just like
dick saucer you know that going in
you're going to get that represent like
five tentacles walking around it's like
what is like any other comic-con yeah
okay so they're all just so like that
they're all giving you attitude there
it's what it's almost like interactive
dinner theater like you get to go there
and actually it'd be Park Deadpool okay
so today has been examples interact with
each other and do shows or anything they
don't really interact with each other
but there is a TV in the bar at all
times playing Deadpool so hands on loop
like a
Oh God and today are the elbows down
once an hour they played the honest
trailer Dibble okay
what's the pricing years as I asked
there it was a prior review rated
connects to another restaurant I would
put it like Chipotle level okay yeah not
too expensive so they're quick it's not
something you have to sit down all the
time spend the whole time you can go
area style and with them at their behind
McCallum and I'm saying food quality
wise is around to pull a style but there
actually is guys the devil comes up to
you and he's like here what do you want
you point to it you write it down and
bring it's not the real Deadpool though
no and iego color and right guys here's
where you're both wrong first of all
Richie Rich is not really known as the
Gandhi character he is a comic character
engine cartoonist it's not like a movie
character there's a little had a hit
movie
okay great film I love the Deadpool but
who knows what the sequel is going to do
who knows when the sequel is going to
come out what could it could have fall
prey to like what Iron Man 2 and
Avengers 2 and and guardians to but
here's a life I went on the movies but
he is a light face because he's a comic
book character he's better known still
even though the movie was great he's
better known as a comic book character
and yes Vito Corleone got his start as
the book written by Mario Puzo but he's
better known he's better known as a
movie character that is the question
what movie character would open the best
I didn't know better nudity character
and here's the thing you've got waiters
and waitresses dressed to the hill
they're going to make evening kids feel
like grown-ups yeah and the Godfather is
timeless so Vito's Italian restaurant
will also be timeless what island
I said pulls [ __ ] Jim bananas whatever
no it's a flash in the pan it'll be here
today gone tomorrow are you kidding me
that's a good cool thing there's gonna
be twenty college yet what's real quick
and just trying to make joke not the
biggest nightmare of all time ya know
dad the whole themselvess would not be
involved with it all I got to show up to
a bit of work meetings first oh yeah did
they just get drama [ __ ] Ryan Reynolds
shows up one for awhile puts on the suit
you don't even know it's him you know
everywhere else we're in the reality of
the business of realities all skewed
here I'm talking about the real Richie
Rich opening up arrest
Ryan Reynolds you got a picture Richie
Richie put up there he looks like a
little Trump I don't want to go to
restaurant although Trump Trump later on
I put it on my leg I put the goshawk
they're like let's put the dog Cory
there you go goodbye remember I would
buy Parmesan and I would take okay NOLA
first of all you're going to be in this
restaurant there's gonna be like a
liquor like some crime family is going
to be sitting there after your knees
you're going to be naughty like honey
does that guy have a gun on him and
you're gonna be like all my other
they're going to shake down owners
they're going to be crazy gonna be a
nightmare why would you ever go to
somewhere here is on yourself just think
you might capital you want to simple
menu you have someone who's read no
crime and Italian is not he does Italian
food adorable you know what you think do
you think we're here guys I don't say
this they're going to be you know she
likes me painted this is maybe unfair
but I looked at Yelp and anyways you
read what I found here oh here we go Oh
Vito Corleone Italian Grill in love it's
our star what does it say wait hotter it
is to say the top though Yelpers report
this location has closed closed closed
stuffed pork tote and yes I nor four
star rating average yeah but it closed
personally I admit that was not the Vito
Corleone I don't know how do we know him
- yeah close I don't know I do nobody
now no key line I call me do you have a
gun no crime no simple man like it's
like sitting where was that restaurant
where was the restaurant Ohio a lot
there you go
you started me too I mean if they don't
the change again and I mean I've got a
state of Ohio you know what it's not
sustainable in Ohio and it's where if
she wishes it to stay here anywhere I'm
here to impress you rich it does not
matter his relative food and the fun the
children the children are the ones who
are going to drive visibility so the
question is movie character which is not
in the restaurant
well it's what movie character is your
question the character went open the
what open the best chamber that's right
it's not doable hunter specific I got it
clarify because you know look this is
your question so I'm challenge you
served as for a chain restaurant has
multiple location it needs to be able to
start up in any city right and be
successful so when your final clothing
as we go through Mike you'll start us
why is it the best chain restaurant how
many how many these in you can
make we can make a lot of them and as I
said before the costs of opening it and
storing and shipping needs specifically
because of the chain restaurant are
going to be brought down so it's going
to be a more profitable profitable
business for people to invest in for
other people to get excited about
because it's so much cheaper than a
normal chain restaurant you want to be
able to ship things out across the globe
and make it cheap that's the number one
reason the second is of course the fun
stuff to slide the ball pit and the the
very simple but very delicious food all
right man final five everybody
everybody respects Don everybody
respects the Corleone family the
Corleone family is going to be able to
keep costs down because of the respect
because of the statement they're doing
Barry's mother anything they're doing
things for each other who knows what
they're doing but here's the thing guys
everybody loves Italian ok look at the
success of Olive Garden and look at the
Peppo then you bring in a famous movie
character yet he's the mob the poor
family is about fighting you know mom
I'm going to tell the moderator
right but you're talking about a
character that everybody loves a movie
character that everybody loved is one of
the greatest movie characters of all
time look it up on the AFI list and
Meryl I'm sure he is on there these
other two characters are not and he's
Italian and everybody was a tank all
right going for the more powerful
character all right let's hear about
Deadpool here's the thing the most
important thing you're opening a
franchise like a new restaurant is
advertising and no one has proved who's
better at advertising with Deadpool his
movie alone I think the success that
movie is really because he's so involved
in every aspect advertising you're gonna
watch TV and be watching a playoff and
Deadpool can come out he's going to make
you laugh as you do sell chimichangas
he's gonna be around the restaurant
throwing nineties until the wall it's
going to be so entertaining yeah you see
he was seeing my specialist you got
swords he's going to be cutting ship
jackets with swords the kids and the
family who me like that's where we want
to go are you sure you want to go to
race your rich kids are gonna say who
they're going to say you sure you want
to go to Vito Corleone
they're like a dad I have no idea what
you're talking about but let's go to
Deadpool that guy looks entertaining it
looks fun and it is experience and look
at all those chimichangas
whoo all right Dan sit on the board this
don't like to go into 19 Richie Rich
where was my collar Colton's last movie
until 2003 the movie about 1994 so that
was the last three young Culkin
filmography Mercer keenbean and that
movie was played by Michael McShane you
might know him as the hypnotist from
office space amongst many other roles
man she went very obscure skewer with
your Godfather quote you didn't quite
get it right to try to be able to the
best in town try to be able to the best
in the city is actually the God for the
quote from the God the points for
obscurity I'm surprised nobody made a
reference to the fact that no one would
want to go to the bathroom it's gotcha
I'm going to say that yeah I'm gonna
need you guys also kept referencing boo
get to Peppo if we're ever going to get
up on the meatball wall of pain it's a
good defensible we want about how do we
know they're right for Spencer's sake I
can get us on that people wall of fame
jce I appreciate the odds a shameless
pandering by thanking not as chair Lee
would play at the Dead Pool I mean why
not it's fantastic and and because it
was broached
I I do have to say factually the Trump
organization's website does list six
restaurants Court is owned and operated
by that little venerable organization to
name so yes this is Richards could
potentially I guess join the moon from
the Donald in the restaurant business
you look William alright based on those
arguments yeah it was weird to me is JT
your there she's chopping up
chimichangas with Zorro in the
commercials in the commercials tissie no
like no he doesn't no one for the
experience yeah didn't you tell me on
the food and a bunch of like disgruntled
peeping people ten full costumes walk
around giving me chimichanga so I'm kind
of gross
so however them all yelling at me maybe
for once but chain restaurant to live
you got to go back multiple times so
yeah it's because if there might be
Manson came down to you but Mike you
were like oh look all this fun will be
so many statues and drawing easels what
happens is both in its light as well for
some things and all the obscure Harvey
carriages very care
man he went on weird direction there
yeah man sir you lost me a little bit
with the pricing I mean how are they
going to make a business with Blitzen
money hand-over-fist
that said where would I rather eat
strangely enough I think I'd probably
want to go to the godfather restaurant
so I think a couple more more often
there yeah I heard a bit more about the
food and the you're going to be treated
classy and the kids came in this sounds
like a fun thing Richie Rich I don't I
don't why is it a Friday because people
avoided the entire regional of Friday I
just got a little confused
it sounded like theme park food that at
that point and then I'd rather get a
nice of Italian meal too man you get the
win but you get two points
they beat Mike on him how winning
advantage rounds last the program made
Philippe you know for the owns Italian
with the second-place
runner-up in the what was the protocol
learn instead voted for Vito Corleone
47% voted for decibels to me I won every
poll of my 16 percent voted for a prize
which I read sure alright well Mike
here's your chance to win because if you
win any needed next advantage rounds you
will get two points all right
JC it's your turn for the advantage
would you like to read your question
sort of thrown out there Bobby no it is
what's the little character again
outside a rocky and rainbow would win it
all out battle royale yes now we took
out rocky Rambo because we thought that
would be unfair those are the two
obviously wins I think everyone would
take yes but still loves done a lot out
of character a whole bunch so this is a
fun one who would win and it's Stallone
battle royale JT who you again
oh the question of the way for my whole
life I've been studying for this and
stay one guys I have to kind of jump
it's got to be Cobra also known as
maryinka bretty the guy just gets
results and I think that's why I chose
him out of all the other characters he
plays he is part of something called a
zombie squad I to this day don't know
what that is but it sounds amazingly
badass it's so badass that no one else
on the force even knows what it is to
the point where they have a guy
surrounded in a grocery store they're
like Colin zombie squad you would think
a whole truck of people have come up one
guy one guy walks out at Stallone
glasses match and the way he walks in
casually he's not even like scared for a
millisecond throughout this entire movie
he is the law too
degree that I've seen before but he's
not restrained by the law and I think
that's what makes him better than any of
the other soil characters because like
it or not they're all kind of they have
some sort of moral code as far as like
where they're standing in the police
print stink and they have something
that's holding the back Cobras the one
guy of all the Sloane characters which
no matter what you put up against
defeats it easily it's night it's very
rare that you see a challenge throughout
this entire movie even guys are like
double his height muscle range and
everything Cobra just absolutely
dominates him and I got more stuff I'm
gonna throw at you but I'm gonna let you
guys my mic which Stallone character you
pickin well I'm going to another iconic
character John Spartan from demolition
man look this guy was in cryo prison for
34 years that is a crazy amount of time
to be in a regular prison let alone a
cryoprison this guy is tough as nails
he is April he was frozen in 1996 so he
has the experience of an old way of
policing and then he's unfrozen years
later - of course capture Simon Phoenix
his arch-nemesis and the scariest
criminal of all time the scariest
criminal on the planet this guy has
experience he works within the law he
understands fighting hand-to-hand combat
but he has a code of ethics and also he
eats a lot of taco Butler and Taco Bell
is maybe the greatest food of all time
so I want a guy who is going to stand
he's going to have rules he is going to
you know play by a book somebody who's a
loose cannon who doesn't respect law I
think is dangerous to himself not to
others Scott alright guys great ticks
I'm going but Barney Ross from The
Expendables wait make that three
Expendables movies that came out in 2010
2012 and 2014 movie are you gonna pick
from over there oh I'm going to go with
which one had Stallone
[Music]
expendable you're picking Stallone from
extendable Expendables one two or three
Expendables one okay edibles one okay
first of all you're talking about a
mercenary a mercenary a leader of
mercenaries a leader who can who can
lead someone like like Arnold
Schwarzenegger Jason Statham just Jet Li
I mean you're talking about someone who
has power around the world not just in
the USA listen I love a demotion man but
I feel like it's more of a comedy it's a
fish out of water comedy so that's out
that's not a strong character Cobra
great film but it's very dated very 80s
it's very cheesy
dog name it's badass I think Barney Ross
from Expendables here's a guy who is a
badass and he's leading badasses
can I start turning down key all right
look take your best shot first things
first let's start with Barney Ross he's
old he's in a Twilight and those movies
really are all about the fact that he
can't do these things without his team
like that mercenary team is what makes
Barney Ross Barney Ross the only time he
ever goes solo in the films he usually
loses and has to go back to his friends
for help and he realizes oh I'm only as
good as my team is Barney Ross he's good
but he's again he's in his twilight
years he's not in his prime he wants to
loan in his prime if he's going to be
going to the Battle Royale their scenes
in Expendables 1 where he's running I
was like stolen looks like he's lost a
step or two like he was like he might
trip any second because he's just not
the right age
he's not in his prime John Spartan first
of all he has a chip in his head which
could make him do things he came via
round like he wants an it every time he
sees anything like a sweater like
there's gonna be things in his brain
that I could really help him connect too
much when it comes to actual fighting
and those Y side effects is good because
he's also programmed to be like a
special super martial artist and
honestly most GG man he gets his ass
kicked by Wesley Snipes once he gets out
of frozen you just get his ass kicked
left and right and here's one thing
Cobra does that these two guys don't
Cobra has those great 81 liners but
every time he uses one it's only to
distract or you know maybe make the guy
think mainly in the beginning when a guy
has a hostage he uses it to distract the
guy and by
sometime he's never given those
one-liners and he's about to shoot
somebody what the biggest issues with
John Spartan every time he's about that
either Leia blonde Wesley Snipes or take
a shot at him he was like no you're
going first like and it gives basically
the villain a chance to do that
Cobra doesn't mess around he shoots he
kills and then he only says stuff unless
it's absolutely necessary Oren has some
sort of purpose he is a killing machine
much more so these two great great long
answer I really watch for that Jesse
here's some problems all those
one-liners you're talking about
Cobra is dated copra is very eager
talking about the movie called about
Harry the Bowery talking about I'm
talking about the character is too dated
all those cheesy one-liners he what they
wouldn't hold water today my heart hang
on hey are you know the do Arnie Ross
okay yeah he may rely on his team but
guess what the whole is greater than the
sum of its parts you're only as good as
your team and the fact that he is a
great team leader and he brings out the
best in his team makes him a stronger
character team isn't going to be with
him though and he does even control team
very well does wandering as a loose
cannon halfway through the first
Expendables film he leaves a t hey no
matter how good of leaders into one of
his best guys leaves and turns on his
own team to say how much good movies
they when did they get there meant did
he get to eat that they did it all turn
out well in the end they said no crackle
doesn't have he's not going up against
people that are that bad he is a guy
work so on first of all it's lame to
have a name for a group that's just you
and that's a weird bad weird things know
there were more that come they all died
we don't know because he never explains
I think he has a love for one to make
himself feel better second he doesn't go
up against anything close to what Simon
Phoenix is so man this guy is able to
like casually throw out some one-liners
he's the guy who is not he is not going
up against the challenge here in base is
insane yet he almost whoa I heard that
almost gets killed
private Thompson from Cobra is the most
insane character Sloane has ever faced
and I remove any movie any movie no come
on Phoenix's laughing joking he's
kicking ass he's making the Jeffrey
Dahmer joke so I'm fighting freaking
Brian tossed a movie is a murderous
psychopathic axe killer who has a cult
with him not only to still take on the
whole cult and kill them
some lemon field he then goes into the
freakin iron factory and he killed this
dude and the best thing about it and
this is what makes coder better both
these guys he says I am where the law
ends and justice begins he basically
says I will go that extra mile where
other people won't let me go that's why
he is so badass that's why he would kill
these guys before you would even say
anything nice doing before you kill him
he would just kill them so you're under
estimating Simon Phoenix here one of the
greatest villainy what am i entertaining
important he's like the Joker he is a
guy who was so crazy that he is not just
an intense axe murderer he is a guy who
gets in your head he psychological it's
not just a guy who like wields a crazy
acts and it's like some some losers are
following on a field Sloane goes into
what feel and kill some people
guy is not going up against the
challenge I would rather fight a guy who
makes a lot of jokes Eames upbeat and
has been trained to do martial arts to a
chip then a guy said it makes it better
so you better at that because he's been
trained by a computer I'm not just your
human being I understand that but I'd
rather fight karate than crazy and Brian
Thompson is beyond crazy he doesn't care
about his life Phoenix wants to live
Brian Thompson just wants to killed me
feel as he can he's a psychopath
Harrisburg's you're both wrong here's
where the belt officer nothing out
because you guys go back and forth the
voice of reason here is that Barney Ross
has the brains and he has the bronze
that you need the bronze to go in the
brains and use evil in the brains in the
movie you tell you're talking about the
expandables you talk about his character
it's relevant for today Barney Ross does
not feel dated like Cobra how is that
going to play in a fight how's that
putting but you're talking about the
movies we're doing here tonight because
he's not just using his muscle he's
using his brains and I feel like like
Cobra is reckless and that worked in his
day by Barney Ross yeah he's got the
broadband you know what don't knock the
guy because he's old he's still freaking
got it let's talk about ratio for it
real quick and as a final thought yeah
one thing I know it's in this movie half
the movie sparked in the shooting at
Simon Phoenix they're not hitting each
other to issue in walls or hand
everything on each other because the
whole movie basically they look very
good people very well know they're just
it's action movie they're not very good
shots and they're just talking it's
already wrong good dodging it
I was just spray balls in the air if you
watched over almost every shot he takes
with that gun lands on a target he's not
doing rainbow he's just shooting into
the sky he's not just like we do almost
every single shot that he shoots out of
his pistol his gun his machine guns
submachine gun hits his target he's the
most efficient killer and of all three
of these by far nighttime the tape to
mike final thoughts John Spartan is
handcuffed in a way by the law by a code
of ethics yeah but he ultimately
succeeds when if he were to take all the
gloves off not have a code of ethics not
believe in law and order he would
actually probably be more powerful but
he succeeds in spite of that which I
think makes him a stronger character
Cobra has the present own rules he just
has a gun he shoots people that's great
he's a scary guy but this John Spartan
character is more powerful because with
restrictions he is able to overcome and
Barney Ross probably dyes his eyebrows
before he goes until Dan sells not the
guy because he sold first of all Spartan
is compared to coab ready and to Barney
Ross
Spartans kind of a [ __ ] he kind of
really is I mean he could stuff like
that it's not as strong and he's just
not as strong as Cobra or as Cabrera or
Barney Ross and again Barney Ross he is
even legend he is a legend who can
command these big guys and they follow
his lead they work together as a team
it's not just about shooting bullets or
punching people in the faces it's about
having the charisma to be a leader in
addition to being a standalone badass
and that is what he is in the
Expendables he's not gonna have a team
all right can this couple clean up
things a zombie squad was an elite
division inside the LAPD of called the
bottom line in lon 11 of which I believe
John Cobra or Cobra was the only red
America Brady was the only surviving
member I feel for sure though they would
never know demolition play a man took
place in 2032 source of a few more years
till we get there supposedly for our
overseas viewers you may have been
confused by Mike or referencing Taco
Bell it's because in the European market
it was replaced by Pizza Hut retouch
there was no taco home so there may be
year but substitute keep the hyper Taco
Bell I'm a big fan Pete so two big
benefits and almost drink yeah the name
self luncheon was thrown around the
piano top one ritalin drunk inside house
who is a like legitimately like a rocket
science yeah it's very easy when you
think about it he's also the second
Kindergarten Cop that's right yeah and
as always we have the viewer poll Andy
which I will share what she's lazy rule
well I got to be honest on this one I
think the advantage definitely played a
part
JT just drop some real knowledge there
of his characters and I think yeah
Spartans got a little bit of that he
doesn't know he's got the rules and I
think Barney's just yes I'm not to knock
the age but it's the team he doesn't
have the team and it's clear he needs
that team so I got to give JT the point
you only earn one point though I know
that if I lost that one I want to walk
down good alright round five mister man
is your turn to offer the advantage you
got to pick this what would you like to
do let's read it off okay let's read it
off here there's only one question for
the man's advantage pitch la-la-land
all right so you're ready come on oh I'm
so ready okay here here here it the
movie that's won best picture for a
whopping two minutes at the academy
whatever you llama man here is the
sequel la-la-land to city of Stars this
movie is going to be darker and deeper
the first movie I thought that the first
movie was a very rose-colored look at LA
it's show business it was it was a love
letter to to Hollywood and Los Angeles
this movie is deeper it's darker it is
going to be the Empire Strikes Back
all right away Halen it's going to be
the Empire Strikes Back of the La La
Land
Cinematic Universe we are talking about
a mood that takes place about times the
biggest eye-roll expenses
I didn't appreciate is that every
parabola now the Empire Strikes Back
what's that back did it by violence to
the matter you're right the Empire
Strikes Back
yes - Trey is the Wrath of Khan oh la la
my ex Cinematic Universe said it takes
place about 15 10 15 years later let's
say 15 years later after the original
film both characters have lost
themselves said has sold out his
business seds has become whether you
know a restaurant chain a food chain
that so that makes fried fried foods
he's become very very successful as Seb
but he has lost his passion he lost his
vision he lost his goal he's rich but
he's unhappy he's also grossly
overweight mia has fallen on hard times
and her roles have dried up she gave up
her career to be a stay at home mom to
be a trophy wife to her husband played
by the guy from that thing you do so she
goes into one of his chains she goes
into one of his never seen Mike breaketh
much she doesn't a lot of his chains and
she sees Sebastian and she's horrified
of what he has become they look at each
other just like they did at the end of
the first movie only this time they
don't smile at each other they both
realize that they are unhappy they even
she leaves and just on a whim she goes
back to Griffith Park where they had so
many fun times original film yeah she
sees Sebastian he's ready to jump off
the cliff at the edge of the park easy
because he is no no I'm serious he is
rent he's he realizes that he had sold
out and that he lost himself and he's
ready to kill himself
and just before he jumps she thinks to
him city a star are you shining cessful
oh my god wait a minute no okay again
this is Anton Stice top of the Lama list
and imagine that
and the midpoint that's just a midpoint
okay so she saves him sort of sitting on
the bench that they sat on near the end
of the first movie of course and they
realize that they've lost themselves and
he says to her because she also gave up
her dream you told me that that people
love what other people are passionate
about they inspire each other to get
back to what they put - back back to
what their dreams were he starts playing
the piano again
she starts going out on auditions she
gets a role in an independent film in a
supporting role variable budget they
need someone to score the music she
recommends Sebastian he does it the
movie goes to Sundance
later in the year it turns out to be a
big hit and they both get nominated for
Academy Awards and this time they stay
together hmm okay
JC you'll see your pitch for la lanterne
so many problems with your pitch yeah
here's the deal um I do not want the
Emma Watson run cough like that Emma and
I my daughter was down
mmm I was done I will get ya I don't
want to see that they've told their
story that theme you said about him like
selling out we saw that in the first
movie so okay I shouldn't be rebutting I
should just be talking online all right
here we go la Liam - I like that's what
I'm going to call it la Liam - the title
tells you that you can tell another la
story that has nothing to do those two
characters but kind of touching the same
themes but a different aspect of the
business
this is la Lin there's so many different
aspects in this business I think you can
use that same kind of themes patella
with new characters and different in
charge and calling it lala land - I'm
calling it lolly in - yeah while we in -
nothing else no extra stuff so I'm going
to take two characters again I'm going
to bring back miles teller who was
originally supposed to star in this film
but couldn't because Ryan Gosling I
guess was better than it I don't know
why but I think mouth teller was so good
and whiplash he showed that he knows how
to work with this director but now he's
a stand-up comedian he's a struggling
Stan of commuting to go to the comedy
store all time he's trying to make he
trying to make it his business which is
so hard anyone who tried to stay have
knows it's one of the hardest thing to
break into he meets a girl who's a
female screenwriter
played by Hailee Steinfeld who's trying
to also break into the business and try
to make screenplays that are different
that aren't just action movies and stuff
and she's it's a lot about her strong
being a woman screenwriter and his
struggle being a comedian they meet each
other and it's a very similar storyline
as far as the first one when it comes to
things because I think the best sequels
like James Cameron does this he hits the
same beats but he does it in a new
different way with a different angle so
you still feel like you're getting what
you want from that first movie but
you're getting a new story and new
characters I think with these two actors
who he'll expect about coming off the
edge of seventeen again what the best
performances I think of last year I
think miles teller is about the best
working actors right now spectacular now
he kind of touched on this and
especially whiplash and I think teaming
up with Damien Chazelle for this sequel
they could kind of capture recapture the
spirit of that first film but tell
stories of different people not the
different themes with different people
and I think the musical numbers can be
really fun imagine doing like a comedy
store number Rawlings is all these
friends you're introduced throughout the
movie and there's like a scene where is
like a fun song where all the other
comedians are kind of like pitching in
and doing thing and Hailee Steinfeld
being on set she actually gets to be on
set for while she's writing some of
these movies maybe she doesn't feel like
they're doing a good job there's a whole
sequence where she's going through the
stage of the sets of the movie and she's
singing about how they're not really
putting her screenplay that she wrote to
good use I think it's Mike have looked
horrified you're a lot attached wait
wait to hear this one yeah I'll get my
pitch hi all right well it's called
Muppets take a lala land okay we don't
want to see the same characters again
their story is completed we want to take
a similar story but look with new
characters and characters that we like
okay Kermit is a struggling banjo
musician hold on a lily pad all right
Miss Piggy is a struggling actress
all right you took Kermit gets a job
with dr. teeth in Electric Mayhem and
their van and cleani for some reason
it's like why would you do that you were
trying to be a banjo solo artist which
whatever and then they basically have a
struggle and there's all your favorites
Fozzie Bear this is going to bring the
Muppets back into what we like a
Hollywood story it's not going to be
like that show where I was trying to
like ground it too much this is going to
be fun glamorous good songs
characters that we love all right well
all the way done okay talkie Calais and
that's very funny that's funny how dare
you disrespect to Oscar almost winning
film like
on land that is a respected Rahman any
chance the mother would be nice [ __ ] you
guy okay you pitched a muffin is it not
hey Dumbo good movie items example of
you throw brothers I really do either I
respect the hell out in both of you your
knowledge your friendship maybe I think
I would take notes for both of you guys
don't I don't even in Chisholm these
pitches are completely crazy here's why
wait
you're laughing at me you're not
laughing engage okay my Kitsch is solid
you personally you think mala land you
think of Ryan Gosling and Emma Stone
people do not want to see other
characters in a movie called mala land
another other characters in a movie
called lala land feels like a
direct-to-dvd rip-off streaming it feels
like a like a b-movie people only takes
them I want to see model and design film
b-movie no no hang on I went to see
model land at the Hollywood Bowl the
18,000 people sold out for two nights I
lost count of all the girls and all the
women dressed like Mia wearing that
yellow dress that Emma Stone wore in
that dress in that movie that movie
touched people these characters touched
people you cannot take the characters
those characters out of the film and
still call lala land it's not while I'm
in first of all that's second about JT
your movie basically is punch line with
the starring Tom Hanks is a little more
current than that you're not going to
make punchline right but no that's what
you pitched you pitched the movie
punchline but Tom Hanks and Sally Field
you did not pitch a lot while annuity
and for you that for both you guys to
say that although their stories have
been done don't want to see the
continuation of these characters that's
total [ __ ] know everything I'm your
boss live I tell any of them who we
didn't end perfectly with how they saw
each other you know I feel like I know
how to create anything
it had a great ending but you know what
a lot of people complained that they
wanted to see Mia and Sebastian end up
together now when we end this darker
sequel in the darkest sequel here's what
our stakes the stakes are high because
like like Sebastian is suicidal because
he
listen you're laughing but I'm serious
yeah I'm serious you know it is it is
depressing it's darker we're talking
like not real guys no in fashion this
show is emotional the emotional impact I
mean go my pitch may sound funny but the
emotional impact that people will feel
when she sees she sings the song that he
wrote for her back to him all those
years later not a dry eye in the house
and people will get what they didn't get
at the end of the first move what they
wanted was to see them end up together
they weren't they were their destiny is
to be together sorry honey was off it
says what she leaves her kids and leaves
her husband she goes losing Ryan Gosling
I feel like you're just going against
what that movie did like I never Pena
was 90% depressing is all I know nothing
without a lot less than top you guys
when I left that theater did you think
god I can't wait to see another movie
with these two caring to see where they
go I don't know anybody that says that
that's why I would introduce new
characters in la-la-land they're still
wallowing and you do it again like I
said you got to redo the same themes
with different characters the same way
you said they play they fell in love
with those two characters just like you
said people are dressed like them who's
to say he couldn't make a seagull you
fall over two totally new characters who
aren't just gonna be carbon copies of
those two but in different ways and have
different kind of attitude III David
explores a different part I get what
you're saying you're saying okay well
let's let's take the theme and apply it
to different characters but your your
theme your different characters again
you just basically pitched me a movie
that's been done and it was called
punchline I have a punch line and again
I'm sorry here my friend Reznor do the
music anyway I mean is 90% right here
now you want the glamour you want some
of the fun of it yeah I like that sort
of the very ends bringing it back they
bring it back to passion they people
love another pin minute at Landover the
movies on you know like the first movie
they gave up the love there they
sacrifice their love for each other that
continue that continued following their
dreams and you know what they realized
that their dreams were to be together
and by coming back together alright they
put their lies offensive from you I got
here more again salmon eyes the this
the musical numbers at the Comedy Store
I mean what is it can be like the jokes
about my apenas did it work tonight like
it's not that bad Comi
not bad and the company does not lend
itself to the glamour and glitz that you
would want a song from lalala these are
like scumbag comedians like you want
like Bill burr singing about like no did
I talk about like getting a [ __ ]
didn't like the best thing doesn't work
the best thing about a good musical is
different very variation in the songs
like that's gonna be one when it's not
fun but it's not true to the stand-up
comedian the type of people that do
stand-up are not people nothing and a
writer an area to make a good musical
but much grain it will ring very false
as far as what stand-up wanted things
are like molten level well I'm not going
to deny that it but more so if it's all
of us and it's like we're getting like
I've got to keep I'm going to pick I'm
going to keep it simple okay your movie
is not lala land
it's a muppet movie it's not a melon but
it's also level it may be a spoof of
lala land which I'm sure someone's going
to do a spoof of lalala sooner or later
but your movie is a spoof it's not
relevant and same ultimately your movie
is plush line it's not wobbling and
miles teller miles teller blame it miles
teller that's who you pitched yeah he
did not do lala land for a reason
what remove that I thought was because
he lost it to Ryan Gosling ah you know
what
I cannot say why not amazing a way to
drive way bringing will that out and
that our renowned mad it's a different
movie he's great at what nah she was
praying to bleep it's spectacular now
look last she could do some of those
similar things that angst somebody who's
struggling through life I need to find
their way all right actually they can do
it all right here so we have a real dark
direct sequel freelance we have the
puppet version with Lizzie we have the
new character version of GTA Lorien new
asides and your closing arguments we
heard the pitch why we want to go in and
reappear listing is I'm you're gonna
help me buy a ticket to one of these
because we got it the audience and I'll
pick on this one why is yours the best
continuation of lala land my and that
can be brought
that doesn't mean literally here here it
is simple I'm not going to talk anymore
just to say this is is for a sequel to
lala land pitch a sequel to la lamp is
my land this is lala land to a
continuation of the story a continuation
of the characters where we get what we
really did want the first time which was
to see them get hurt
get it into sequel Gigi I think allowing
is more than just two characters I think
it's about the themes about what's
representing in more importantly
Hollywood in LA and what happens in the
experiences that people have here one of
the things that's so great Belen it's so
many people have different experiences
and you explore it with new and
different characters I'm not talking
about putting some b-movie actors in
here I'm talking about two people were
some of the best young actors working
today who can make you fall in love them
just like you did with Emma and Ryan
Gosling and David yourself coming back
he's not going to make punchline - he's
going to make a great sequel to lala
land that I think would absolutely be on
par with the first one it could even be
nominated for stuff I can't say movie a
nominee for anything and I think it's a
dis justice to the first film to
continue that story when I think it
ended I can't think of a better ending
for La Land one of the best things about
that movie was the ending and that's I
don't want to ruin that I don't want to
ruin that ending with a sequel like what
movie do you want to see I've three of
these I know this may be similar to the
model movie with the Muppets need a
movie to reset them although other other
Jason Segel mumble movies were fine but
this is a movie the spirit of lala land
the fun the pageantry the big musical
numbers in this movie honestly make the
most sense as far as this this is a
crazy dark movie I don't know what would
be happy with this people would be so
absolutely very upset that they love
lala land and they only watch the goo
the characters get overweight and
depressed and like there would be people
would be foaming at the mouth of they
saw this and then was your how they
would I don't want to do a movie like oh
that's weird and then they'd be like I
love Kermit these musical numbers are
delightful and as far as this the world
just doesn't make sense you can't have a
glamorous musical that's fun at the
comedy store these books look I do i
nominees are over living these are using
a mr. scumbags people people don't want
to see these people we also have only
sure about people who wants to see that
metal before a lot long and a lot of way
it it's fun by the way you talk about a
movie before it ended and it felt like
everything wrapped up at the end a movie
that did not need a sequel but a got one
and it was actually really damn good
Star Wars Star Wars ended I don't know
hang on cereal death but no was a big
thing was a standalone movie it was a
standalone movie that had a great ending
it would have been just fine they just
left it at the end of that and what did
it get it got
get our car back tomorrow is an
action-adventure hi man it's me damages
me over there
listen mr. Parker's done with all of us
for everything
this is a hard call many probably and
frustrating things see him out of that
round I love my land
yeah me too had an eye I look low I used
to think we're on the same page first of
all Scott his name is Tom Everett Scott
he plays guidance a drummer for the
wonders Joseph Rio do Donna I will say
it's very enticing to know the viewers
who are usually very polite and nice got
a little nasty during this round oh I
will say that there is there's a
favorite both of the pole and just
through reaction and and a couple of
audience things that I can't say before
Andy gets to his judgment I will say I
have a favorite one that I would go see
oh hi by far I want to hear some of you
on it so Andrew sitting there help me
which one would you buy the ticket to
and tell me why and I go unconventional
I go through the Muppets more I read he
sold me on the lifeboat has a good music
I love the Muppets it's not along
everything I wanted so long I have the
same problem of everyone I'm definitely
on cortical yes you're lonely and here's
the problem
yeah both of these movies in a way I
mean JT did say too but I'm not getting
together was sort of the point of the
movie so when they go he's killing
themselves and do it only and then they
get together yeah it really leaves sort
of a sour taste in what lala land is and
then JC I like this side you have new
characters but to perhaps green writer
in the comic I don't know I just felt
you were closer yeah but yeah basically
I'm kidding I gotta go mom you
yeah yeah and recoat the Muppet really
and what I was going on over there the
audience called it's white 15 minutes
ago the audience the audience called
this fight after Mike's opening
statement by far the only answer for
anybody watching I hate them more the
problem is I think what how does the
only answer for people watching the show
live I'm going to be honest it was the
only answer for me and I love lala land
and that's still the only one that I
personally wouldn't go hard
so I'm glad I we were all damaged I
wasn't online but I'm glad we are but
can agree for once yes that boarding
Mike in the lead with three points is
u-turn - I'm already four percent voted
for Muffet ah but here's what's
interesting though Scott and GC are tied
at two points whoo
all right so how much how long is the
show been hi - I feel like we shouldn't
do this bonus question a little long ray
oh yeah okay so I'm not cut right well
which is a tie-break between then we
have time going back to my kids look
let's do it mama says a tie-break okay
am I in the tiebreak no you're not okay
could I go pee yes yeah all right well
we were going to ask this movie question
favorite movie
we were going to have Mike debate et but
I'm going to cancel his out because he's
out anyways and sweet that means manse
we're going to basically we're picking
the favorite movie that you were known
for on this show
yeah so manse Wrath of Khan jce rocky so
we're going to do this in a speed round
approach hydral so you do not offend me
why this is the better film Wrath of
Khan
versus Rocky everyone clear wearing to a
speedrun let's give them what are we 30
seconds to go 36 to 37 days 15 30 and 15
perfect I love it
save them for that all right no wait see
there but yeah that's fine enough we can
lose that one okay then we're adjusting
our bonus just in case I wanted to have
it just in case because the point system
shifted a little bit this game but now
Wrath of Khan vs. rocky let's
I have a number behind my back closest
to it went for two I should have
clarified try it again two three yes you
can pick three okay now that's cool Wow
all right Katie you'll go first or
second I'll go I'll go second okay here
we go man still have 30 seconds on the
clock time begins when you begin
speaking okay Star Trek to the about the
kind Citizen Kane of Star Trek movies
the only movie that transcends the
series and decide by genre itself and
deals with the universal themes of
getting older harkens back to
Shakespeare Melville and Charles Dickens
the stakes are high has it all action
heart tumor strong characters great
action two-seamer Spock dies is so
emotional the Leonard Nimoy Dwayne shot
at the top of the game while Carlmont on
one of the best villains ever it's
devastating and it's a movie that you
watch over and over and over and over
again okay just read on that by the way
well so i alright hold on okay so yeah
Rocky is one of the best ones all-time
it's an AFIS top hundred I believe Ron
number 56
it wasn't nominated for four different
Oscars and won best picture for Stallone
in uh early clear and Robert turned off
her producers the lone created a
character that has stood the test of
time people was fussy movie they go
that's the Rocky of this after Rocky and
that people don't really talk about
Roscommon so much they go that's the
Empire Strikes Back of that rap account
I'm sorry to say it doesn't really hold
up too much to me when I watch it felt
dated I've let you really know Star Trek
you can't go into that movie and really
get all out of it unless you knew that
series Rocky
let's disagree Star Trek to the Wrath of
Khan transcends Star Trek it is the
movie that all the other Star Trek
movies and those sequels are judged
along with the Empire Strikes Back it is
a movie that you do not need to be a
Star Trek fan you didn't have to watch
the original episode it is just a great
movie that heads it has more than Bach
the action hearts humor and whatever 15
seconds rewriting top 15 yeah
I disagree i watch Star Trek real common
last year I saw some effects Rao also
there's of suliman's history of the
Shatner's character Nia Kirk I didn't
know what was going on it was like
weird kid the effects look really bad
it's not a good film rocky as the icon
it's too low nominee for Oscar towards
so many more sequels that did wait
better he was down there last year 50
now I'm gonna know it does not move our
sequels the way there were rocky sequels
are better than them alright well I want
to give you give me ten more seconds cut
through the [ __ ] what's really the
heart of the matter here why is rocky
better than Roger Khanna is Rafa Khan
better than rocky go ahead five seconds
rat khan has more than rocky rocky
ratrock on is about friendship ratha
khan has action it has humor it has
heart it is devastating the history of
these characters one of the guys okay
titty Rocky is more iconic he the more
famous character in that movie the
reason why it worked today and does it
feel deed because it's about the
character it's about the interaction him
and Adrian and all the supporting cast
that movie is a perfect film when it
comes to acting hey Andrew what do you
think Mo's arguments
I gotta go wrap the con Oh what did you
hear on the arguments that you liked I
know it's not more passionate passion
how dare you question my passion all
right hyoeun serious fashion Hoshi no I
got passion for my dress clothing we're
building we're both very passionate
about Vince we are I didn't hear as much
criticism against rocky I think as I
heard against Wrath of Khan so that to
me was the outlier I think man she told
me why it's a good film but I did hear
more from Gigi as to why man at the
cloud arrives I have some flaws so for
that reason alone I thought they both
are pretty passionate so but that's the
card for me so I got to give GP the
tiebreaker JC gets it but very close
round of applause for man woo Bravo I'm
going to go to the park and jump off a
cliff
our United for me just for getting movie
man we should point out that that point
does not carry yeah I carry over my
chance to play better in the speed round
yeah so Mike still healthy man JC okay
no pressure there got it
all right now man cuz where you get your
revenge oh seung-ah
Matthew can help me here and here you'll
be helping me here because Dan cannot
because that would be unfair that's true
how did you feel that last rolling dance
so far on the show I'm just curious I I
would have 100% gone and I love Rasik on
but I would have never sat down with jte
he got a really good argument in there
it's like they don't call things there
at the cons of movies they call them the
Empire Strikes Back like that's a really
interesting way to look at it and then I
agree and they landed it knocking rocky
at all he was on the defensive yes I can
put in the game you have to play both
got to play both sides alright here we
go
speed around you know how this works
girl the marbles the winner of that like
Mon Carlton like JD one of you will
finally get that seat against the
champion over there you might be able to
taste that belt will go adult in my
mouth shivers potatoes oh oh here we go
I got some weird ones here wouldn't want
any other way round one here we go boss
baby or Captain Underpants half on his
maybe oh hey I heard JT I heard Mike
first and you said bottle he said it
first
no sorry I'm losing track what did you
say JT character shows first okay
Captain Underpants and boss baby for
Mike alright
you're first JT whenever you're way
cast iron attentions based on a very
popular book that kids actually love and
they actually did it they actually took
the book from screen and made it better
than what it was that's one of the
hardest things to do with movies talking
with boss maybe it's a one joke thing
it's alec baldwin talking like a little
baby it's kind of dumb capnography has
actually had some really fun elements
that kids could be too and the kids who
protagonists are messing with the
teacher what's something every kid loved
to do
it's a fantasy club for kids alec
baldwin elevates anything he's in boss
baby is a very funny idea look a baby
should not be a boss a boss should be a
tall person a regular-sized person it's
not this is a baby this is seeing a baby
do all the things a boss has a million
things it fires people it puts things
together goes to a boardroom
seeing a baby do all of these different
things that are bosses which is infinite
is very funny and interesting captain
under fights do some kid dressed up it's
not once again I go back to boss maybe
it's a one joke film there's nothing
else there it's just out following doing
a stick
captain pants actually tells the fun
story where the character actually learn
something by the end of the movie they
learn a respect your teacher but no one
knows what Captain Underpants is shtick
is at least Alec Baldwin has just
checked the stick that we all know about
so at least I know what boss baby is all
about with a phobia a casual viewer they
know who boss baby is as a character
whoo I will take the record they're both
very OneNote but that's fine based on
their arguments yes manse where he
stands ice to go JT because he I like
that he said that there was a message to
it it wasn't just a stick movie he and I
didn't see either film but I thought JT
a the stronger ones have a message did
you actually see the films were guessing
the book baby
what I do see behind mode the reason I
didn't see was because one note Joe
garelli but whether he made it up or not
he's right but what my both have
messages but I think I'm fans as a
different message little bit more I
thought that you can't chime in den
Andrew I have to go class Pedro is that
dig in at the end that I know the
character going in I don't know anything
about Captain Underpants
just seem confusing watching the trailer
for it but I was confused at the further
end in their most confusing so the
camera which is not an actual yet the
principle under hypnosis to the old it's
very confusing
I don't know instead that they're very
premises yeah but yeah that wasn't that
was Mike's best point but I heard more
than that from Gigi in the first round
so I gotta give GT the first point yeah
so we're tied okay ah baby always create
applause baby
alright here we go best movie featuring
Brendan Fraser the mummy and seen oh man
oh I mean all right she's here first the
mother of the first time I saw Brendan
Fraser had something else in Jessica
median he actually showed that he could
be almost like a Indiana Jones type i
watch this movie we do now absolutely
blown away by how much fun I was having
he nails the one-liners it's such a thin
line between be able to pull off an
action film and actually having a humor
to bounce the Beaufort he didn't Emily
fantastic it's fun it's got horror it's
got special effect it's a summer
blockbuster Encino man is a fun and
unique movie in the 90s and it takes my
former boss Pauly Shore and it makes the
best thing he's and he's great we love
him in a death thing the launches career
Brendan Fraser is great he's so likable
and it's it's own unique thing mommy is
just sort of this Indiana Jones ripoff
and it's fine but it's not that
memorable really I don't remember a
single thing about it when I'm thinking
back to seeing her when the theater and
seeing a man is something where you
remember nobody remembers Encino man
that's Pauly Shore and Shawn acids movie
and he is almost like weekend at
Bernie's bow in the cave man it's just a
dumb premise that when you watch it
you're like whatever The Mummy actually
has scenes that are spectacular the same
reason that oh I think it's a suit and
CEO man is a movie with a dumb premise
that pulls it off and is memorable The
Mummy and what had what is there's a
mummy and I don't remember he runs away
from a big cloud of dust that's all I
really remember I mean
perfect you back summer point answer
company yeah hey jakey we'll talk after
this yeah hi Andrew based on those
arguments JC it's not like he hit more
points on the money and why it looks
better man
I like Mike's argument I came up with my
why I have the same problem I don't
remember anything my mommy
anyway when you said it let me see your
pathetic one when I think any money I
take a Raiders of the Lost Ark cuz
that's what's up uh family is unless you
got more specific it might have helped
JT we'll get that point but I gotta get
I gotta give Mike the point with man sir
yeah JC is an unforced error what I say
when your opponent says there's only one
memorable scene from the movie and then
you say that's the scene of excess faxes
no no no okay it isn't on the clock
that's it yeah
no notice you know no all right a little
bit here we go number three so we're
still tied okay all right I know you're
ahead by one I might thing I had to have
liquor all right best moment in a movie
where a character says the movie's title
oh the rock
[Music]
10 seconds it's Oregon for the movie
right best moment in a movie
5 seconds 2 seconds for the whiff walk
hard they might have said it well art
well I got I got a believe yes ok sure
amazing at some point you know what I
have looked forward to this I got it
look I got it up now ok yeah all right
here we go JT took in the song ok ok oh
when we saw the trailer for the rock we
knew exactly what they're talking about
Alcatraz a scene but maybe seals were
going to go with Sean Connery to break
into one the one prisoner you can't
break out of the whole movie builds up
to this point where they go underwater
and hereís this guy is a bad guy but you
kind of like him you know it's been [ __ ]
it's all gonna come down to this one big
conclusion when they have to face each
other in the scene where Sean Connery
opens the door after go through like the
spinning furnace okay there was
description yeah walk hard walk hard
look they've seen where john c reilly
and kristen wiig on the kitchen this is
a very underrated very funny movie in
the moment he says walk he has to walk
hard it leads right into the titular
song of the thing which is very very
hard yes there are nose it feels
exciting and not in do I know I don't
know I look up whether walk are just it
is okay going solo got a couple buffer
okay and the moment is that it's a very
fun moment because it sends up the trope
that in every other movie where like
somebody gets their hit song and it's
always something so contrived so they're
taking that moment they're sending it up
they're making it very funny and then
they're leading right into the song walk
hard which is a very funny Johnny Cash
parody which is a great moment the lines
of rock in the rock is one that follows
a great moment go through this crazy
death trap of a furnace he comes out and
only the way Sean Connery can't deliver
it has a great actor it says welcome to
the rock and you're on board
so here's Michael more time yes that's
not like it's 10 seconds to say ok
alright the moment welcome to the rocket
just like he was saying hey here we are
we're at the thing heart is actually the
main moment of the best
when the movie really takes off that is
been that is the core of the movie in
that moment so and really lamp I'll take
the blame for part of that but not the
whole thing Andrew I go JP it's knotted
yeah I know when we have a better car
yeah oh yeah I'm gonna be welcome to
Jurassic Park close down oh yeah I'm the
good one all right Andy I agree you get
the points we're tied again
okay just know that was third word
Gordon for an assist a little more
question but okay I'm sorry Matt -
ticket picking from this list okay here
we go
if Rick Moranis would return for just
one new film what role do you want him
to revisit Honey I Shrunk the Kids
Little Shop of Horrors
so my god I didn't get this far back in
this park all right Little Shop of
Horrors versus sorry you said a friend
kiddo all right Mike you're first this
time okay a little shop before is is a
beloved movie it's something that people
really love and would like to see again
Honey I Shrunk the kids are like kind of
schlocky now like straight-to-dvd movies
that he did like he did three of them no
one is really interested in seeing that
little child before is at least is an
interesting idea that you would maybe
want to see where he's at where that
character is that what that universe is
like because there were so many fun
characters there's so many different
side plots that we would be very excited
to go see and explore that universe
again city
I want the honey from the kids because
Rick Moranis could actually benefit from
lawyer we are now a technology you saw
it man the things they did with that
film the 3d like for the first time I
felt like something was actually Shrunk
the Rick Moranis could actually continue
a storyline with us he's always doing
adventure you blow up a kid he's
targeted it could be a whole new
adventure when's yours it's just it's
kind of lame some like where are you
going with that
the technology has nothing to do with
Rick current Miranda has performance
that's just like maybe that goes ant
will look better my movie is something
that people would be excited real honey
intrepid kids like everyone's favorite
Rick Moranis movie no one would want to
see that again
people love will shoppers told its story
it's a very well-known story there's
really no where else to go with it the
plant dies Honey I Shrunk the Kids he's
a mad scientist you can continue that
story McManus does nothing better than
playing the lovable scientist to the
family man that's okay
whoo Andrew based on their arguments and
they go Little Shop of Horrors I'd want
to see that more I was sold more I
wanted to hear a dark Honey I Shrunk the
Kids and power strikes back up the man's
what do you think man was arguing I was
kind of intrigued by seeing where the
character was going to go and the
continuation Honey I Shrunk the kids
I'll go with JT Wow
okay back to me yeah where I was stuck
when she sort of done them a lot and
then as you said he steamed it was a
good point he's sort of been stuck in
that treading of those direct sequels
there's a lot of that universe in Little
Shop of Horrors that isn't killing to me
although your technology thing was a
good argument you it would look really
cool nowadays I thought we have a min
you can say that but yeah I kind of go
over the fact that we've seen so many of
them already into direct sequels to have
them come back to that seems a little
weird so I give you Mike that point Wow
okay so got one if you got to win this
one to force a tie correct right huh
this game is tough in honor of the
Pentagon Papers what movie has the best
ensemble cast
JFK Boogie Nights JFK and Boogie Nights
stumble cast iron JFK first Mike you're
ready when you're was JFK oh yeah
Oh chicken oh sorry I urge okay first
before you go sorry Jessica hi Gigi I
mean I could just list all the actors in
that movie I mean Kevin Bacon Tom Lee
Jones
Walter Matthau John Candy he takes
actors like Kevin Bacon and he puts them
in situations that you wouldn't really
see him and shows you another side of
each actor
Trk me play that Mississippi governor oh
my god that's amazing I've never seen
John Kane do some like that all those
characters are killing Joe Pesci Kevin
Costner who plays perfect in that film
Boogie Nights is an amazing cast that
it's a utilizes the cast the best of
almost any movie I mean there are sign
characters that barely have very much
screen time but you remember them so
well like William HMAC john c reilly of
philip Seymour Hoffman's character I
know he probably has 15 lines I remember
it so vividly I remember the character
this is a movie that crackles to life
every single person matters in this
movie the cast is incredible they all
went on to do amazing things in the
discipline looking Knights is good but
they don't disagree with Don Cheadle I
felt like at times wasn't really
explored enough nor other characters
that were just kind of touch upon these
characters aren't asked to do too much I
have to do just enough scenes with Gary
Oldman Karen throughout this film
sterlin given that speech my movie asks
everybody to do a very a lot with a
little and they do it they they they
crackle to life they may they make every
the most out of every moment this is
this movie more than JFK is something
where you remember every character every
perp Wow that was a tough one
ah yeah what I heard and I like JT gave
me a really good list and he did it
would put those people in different
places that we had we don't expect them
but then might give me a bit more of the
memorable ness of each one that's where
I'm on the fence man's word thought that
was that's tough you know I got to go
with delay more with a little for Boogie
Nights like and really painted house
with you this was a tough one awesome I
mean I've seen both movies and I don't
remember anything about JFK what
co-washing
I gotta go with Boogie Nights on this
one also the small screen time for the
characters really stuck with me yeah I
mean I wouldn't go as far as I don't
remember but I don't disagree I get your
point of what you're trying to make of
it Boogie Nights is more memorable with
its cast
and with its performances so think I got
it that's what an ensemble cast is it's
not just a celebrity list if the
characters you relate to and so I heard
a little bit more of that from Mike so
Mike it's the point and therefore Mike
he gets the win my Carlton is another
shot at the belt Wow look at this
i impressed sir Wow good job
Dan Majerle sweating over there were you
thinking that one eye I knew that
whomever would graduate from this panel
would be a subcontinent and Mike will be
fighting one on one for the hardware and
I can't think of any one strategy is
more antithetical to mine that my
Carlton because I am going to be a very
interesting title fight know for sure
I'm excited a JT and movie mance wow you
guys really brought it today were very
close effort there got to give each of
you thanks JC on JT movie thanks on
Twitter on Twitter JT movie thanks
YouTube also I do a daily show on the
anchor app where I just talk about
movies and what was going on out there
check it out do check it out Mike
Carlson have fat Carlson what would you
like to send the crowd to uh same stuff
I've been saying Netflix movie handsome
complicated I'm in if you go to my
Twitter it's on a little dive a little
roll in
Craig Healey clip co-hosts i watch did
you watch it oh yeah great crazy uh yeah
and you know follow me on instagram i'm
a parody of louie and all the shows
crashing oh yeah yeah
so yeah check me out there good job
killing it he can catch me on Access
Hollywood and Access Hollywood live or
you can just follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at movie man moving man
savetti of stars go you shine brightly
today not that one of my favorite around
I mean a lot of people got upset but I
loved it why do people get upset Oh
retweet we agreed Twitter Dan Majerle
Murrell din on Twitter and such Admiral
Dan on Twitter and such and yeah time to
go to the training and yeah I think I
cup yep in the next month or so
that fight we're going to line our
schedules and make this a big to-do and
it's gonna be a it's going to be a barn
burner it is on and Mike Carlson Dan
Merle and I'll be gone next week's Dan
we'll be stepping in to judge a special
picks our fights next week Perri
Nemiroff and picks are serious John and
some job and a thirst TBD TBD
but Timmy good show so tune in Andrew
coming thank you so much for having me
this is a blast hope you had fun you
were instrumental in this one and thank
you all at home for watching as always
we love you and we will be back next
week at the same time same Channel have
a good one
[Applause]